Ernie Johnson back here on the show how
are you Arne rich I'm I'm just doing
great today my friend fantastic how'd
you like to comment below wonderful
how'd you like your time in the City of
Angels for the all-star game
busy as always you know what I'll start
all-star weekend is it's just non-stop
or kind of pushed and pulled and in a
variety of ways and in addition to doing
the shows so it's it's a lot of work but
it's a lot of fun too and the weather
was beautiful out there we had to set
outside staples over there near LA Live
and it was a it was a lot of fun man we
had a great time yeah yeah the game was
fun - it was and you also had to learn
the base for Fergie's national anthem
right you're the one who playing that
one right there yeah we could have we
could have used a couple more rehearsals
the game was fun I thought Ernie that
the intention to shake things up was
personified at the very end that it was
Durant teaming up with LeBron to beat
Steph Curry now that is good eats that
was fun to watch and watch LeBron and
Cara and and Durant chest bump like they
just won the finals together no it was
it was uh it was a crazy it was a crazy
vibe and I you know I was sitting right
behind the LeBrons bench team LeBron and
I was amazed at how many times in the
course of the evening there were guys
standing up applauding good defense and
and you just don't see that on all-star
games and then it comes down to that
last possession and you got a team that
has Steph Curry on it unable to get a
shot off before before the games before
the game ends it was a yeah it was it
was really it was really an entertaining
game I think it was one of the best I've
seen
yeah and now comes the second half of
the season the story entering it is what
base you can tell the race for the top
spot in home court in the West between
Golden State in Houston obviously with
Golden State looking up at them right
now but also for me Cleveland you know
let's see if the if the deals have
really changed things if they've
reenergized LeBron James apparently they
have and I you know and this is a team
that hasn't lost since they made the
deals and so let's see if let's see if
that's been enough to to get Cleveland
backwards where and where it should be
in the favorites role in the Eastern
Conference and
so those are a couple of them and of
course the San Antonio thing is kind of
intriguing right now what's going on
with that is Eco no extra there there
Ernie sure feels like it it does kind of
feel like it but here's the here's the
situation when you're dealing with a guy
like Kawhi Leonard who is notoriously
quiet he's even more so now and so you
you know really don't understand where
he's coming from you just you know you
read things and you say and you hear
reports from loge and others that yeah
he's been cleared to play but he doesn't
want to play right now because he
doesn't want to play through the
discomfort right now and and part of
that you understand when you look at a
guy who's you know next year is a huge
year for him because he's got an option
for the following season and so he does
he want to play if he's not really ready
to come back he's already tried that
once this year and it didn't work and so
you know that you hear Pop's say that
that he doesn't expect to see him and so
I don't look I'm not going to pretend
that I know that there's anything going
on between Kawhi Leonard and the San
Antonio Spurs organization it's just
very strange I can't recall a time when
we were talking about hey what's going
on in San Antonio you know is it our
things not you know Rosie's like they
always are and so I can kind of see you
know the precautionary stands maybe that
Kawhi Leonard is taking hear about not
wanting to play if he's not ready to
play but man that's yeah you don't often
see stuff like this coming out of San
Antonio and it's the quote before the
line of I'll be surprised if he gets
back this year that caught my attention
Ernie and that's this one if by some
chance he's gonna be pretty late and
it's going to be pretty late into the
season and it'll be a tough decision how
late you bring somebody back that's why
I'm trying to be honest and logical and
because to me it would mean that that
you that you'd think Kawhi Leonard would
be one of those players where it doesn't
matter about knocking rust off you got
to get him out there right yeah you
would think that I mean he is at that of
that exelon of player in the NBA where
you say man if I can get him at all I'm
gonna use it right and and then to say
that well you know I don't know if we
can get incorporate him you know it's
going to be late in the year
it sounded like a message being sent
what it's not like to me that's there a
lot of moving parts on that thing and
I'm not exactly sure how it's all going
to shake out aside to say that if San
Antonio doesn't have Kawhi Leonard then
they're out in the first round possibly
so let's talk about some rules changes
that's being bandied about in the sports
world just about a half an hour ago Zach
Lowe of ESPN saying that the league is
seriously considering having a plan
speaking of NC double-a tournament a
playing for the seven and eight seed
seven and eight plays each other for the
seventh seed and the loser plays the
winner of 9/10 for the eight seed what
do you think of that Ernie oh that's the
first I've heard of that today so well
that's you know that would be that would
be kind of an intriguing deal we're
talking about a series we're talking
about one game one game seven plays a
winner gets the seven seed and then the
loser of plays 9/10 winner for the eight
seed one game each Wow and I imagine
again just well while you're soaking it
in what I what I my first blush reaction
was okay so that's for extra if you will
playoff games to be divvied up between
turner and ESPN one would assume and
then when you've got a Bulls team that
puts out a press release saying we're
gonna see what our young kids do which
is kind of putting lipstick on a tanking
pig in a way to be honest with you you
know and there they would just be four
games behind a ten seed right now so to
me this seems like an anti tanking idea
to also get some excitement generated
and some revenue generated yes yeah
trying to tell people the head don't
ever think your cheer out of it because
you may not really be out of it you may
have a chance to make it's almost like
the wild card game in the Major League
Baseball where you know you've got one
game and a chance to move on so yeah
it's kind of intriguing I don't know if
I don't know that I've digested it
enough to say that's a good idea or a
bad idea rights but it's certainly to
your point
anything you can do to make teams feel
like there's still reason to play and
play hard and and not try to say that
yeah we want to take a look at these
guys or as Mark Cuban just came out and
said you know he tanking wouldn't be a
bad idea you know I think I think
anytime you can try to reverse that
reversed
that course you know I'm up for that
well what do you think about what the
Commissioner floated during his press
conference that the 16 teams that make
the playoffs just get seated 1 through
16 based on record regardless that time
I've got no I've got no problem with
that neither do I know I mean and I was
kind of looking at it right now and
seeing how how that would impact things
as we speak and you know looking at the
record of you know 30 and 28 with Miami
as the number 8 seed right now and and
play the Clippers and the Jazz are in
that mix too so right now you've got
like 18 teams that would that would you
know be in that mix to make the playoffs
oh I don't I don't know if you could
want to do both of those things you know
have a play in game and do 16 I don't
know if I I can't wrap my head around
all of that right now but I think the 1
through 16 I think sometimes is it would
not be a bad idea because because you
can have a good year especially right
now you can have a good year out west or
a relatively good year out west and be
watching the playoffs while you're
seeing a team in the east make it in
there so yeah I don't have but I don't
have an issue with that okay and then
know as the voice of MLB on TBS earning
and somebody that has been steeped in
the tradition of this game as long as
you have in baseball with your dad and
with you I don't know if it pierced your
world of basketball traveling as well as
also just being an all-around great
human on a daily basis in the world an
MLB executive of positing an idea to me
that I mentioned on my show a couple
days ago where you could in the ninth
inning of the game of which you're
losing put any three batters you want up
regardless of order I don't that one has
pierced your ears until just now I'm not
I'm not liking I'm not liking that at
first blush no I don't that that totally
changes it's you know it totally changes
the way you look at things in the
seventh and eighth inning as well when
you're trying to look at okay I want
these guys facing this guy because if we
get them three up three down then I got
these guys coming up now I don't I don't
like that that's no that's that's too
gimmicky for me yeah that the well I
mean but it would also be the the theory
is
is that when the games online LeBron's
not sitting on the benches because it's
not his turn up you know that's but
that's the wait but come on that's the
way that's the way it works that's the
way it works in a nine man sport come on
he can't know I'm too gimmicky too
gimmicky and I don't want to turn it
into a rock and jock softball game come
on let's let's just play baseball so
you're saying the three batters you
would not put up would be John Bongiovi
Morris - exactly and if you hit it right
here
you know you get three extra bases no I
don't like that ok very good
I'm not going for that and then the
n-c-double-a turn its coming up it's
very exciting time in your world is all
I love that man it's you know what
before we ever had a chunk of it I used
to love March Madness just just to hang
out just sit around and watch games and
and and for us to be part of it now for
men it's been years working with CBS
it's awesome and and I know there are
days on those first two days Thursday
and Friday which are extremely long days
in the studio you know and Kenny and
Chuck you know well every now and then
say man I mean I stick break or I said
look if your boss told you all I want
you to do on Thursday and Friday this
week is just watch the tournament yeah
you'd say sign me up we'll do that and
and so yeah it's great and we're looking
forward to having the selection show on
TBS for the first time Greg Gumbel will
be there with me we'll be down here in
Atlanta it's it's it's a fun time and I
just I think it's one of those events
rich and I love it because it kind of
shrinks the world a little bit and it
brings people together and it you know
folks in the office who may not normally
talk to each other find each other you
know standing next to the coffee machine
talking about South Dakota State and
we're you know do I you know you think
you're gonna you know should we take
them is is 15 gonna be two - I think and
anything that kind of brings people
together and and and they don't always
have to be die-hard sports fans I think
that's a good thing and then of course
offices get torn apart when somebody
doesn't know anything about college
basketball wins the pool that's which is
which is the way always hey do I have
time for one quick story go for what do
you ever and it's and this is about you
because I have a friend who's a delta
flight attendant okay and when the Super
Bowl was over you were flying out of
Minneapolis and
on a Delta flight correct yes sir
correct yes sir and they brought a woman
from whose husband was sitting in coach
and they brought her up to sit in first
class if she had the seat next to you
and I just heard from this unnamed
flight attendant who said this guy was
so caring and so helpful for this woman
who needed some help and and I asked who
is this guy and they said oh you don't
know that's that's Rich Eisen from from
the NFL Network and she just and she
sent me this email said what a great guy
he is and when how caring he was and and
so I thought you know I shouldn't just
keep that to myself and next time I'm on
Rich's show I'm gonna point out that it
folks you don't know him he's the real
deal thanks I'm so well done Matt I
really appreciate that thank you very
much for for sharing that and you know I
don't say except thanks appreciate it
you got you the mouth thanks Ernie we
all pay it forward right you know time
so that's what it's all about any chance
we can that's for sure absolutely
Ernie you're the best we'll chat soon
rich great talking to you man you got it
you got it that's at Turner Sports EJ
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience